[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ayew merci si ward intéressant de
rencontrer comme laurent vallet l'a dit
précédemment il plaisantait sur ce titre
propagande et propagande et démocratie
et le fait que ses deux rivaux
bien qu'il semble antagonistes contraire
ne sont pas si loin l'un de l'autre et
tout votre travail
ce que nous avons vu dans le
documentaire le montre nous sommes dans
un monde différent aujourd'hui
nous pensons être dans un monde
différent différent de celui d'édouard
bernès est ce que c'est vraiment
différent qui serait que sa réaction si
l'on vit aujourd'hui il est mort à l'âge
de plus il avait 102 ans 110 ans à sa
mort l'application dans le monde
numérique
mais quelle sur ses réactions
s'il reconnaît que ces histoires
d'algorithmes cette technologie en
peigne chaque domaine entre je pense que
nous sommes pleins rempli d idée de nous
aimons bien pensé que nous avançons dans
la vie ça fait partie aussi lieu de la
façon dont les médias fonctionnent les
médias d'information avec un cycle de 24
heures dans les informations
de ce fonds les médias c'est que il se
repose sur le fait que chaque journée
est quelque chose de nouveau c'est pour
ça qu'on dit que ce sont des nouvelles
le résultat c'est que cette fascination
pour les nouveautés du présence et sa
oblitère aussi chaque journée consumer
brûle les informations de la veille je
génère une amnésie historique qui se
trouve sur qui nous empêche de voir en
fait de voir les écrits de ménez
berne est sûr très heureux du fait que
les technologies qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui avec le big data
c'est que ça diagnos sentiments profonds
et gens sur leur comportement en ligne
lui se dirait que c'est exactement ce
que je cherchais dans les années 1920 je
voulais comprendre d'abord quelles sont
les motivations qui meuvent le public ou
les masses j'étais aussi intéresser les
gens là n'ont l'intention gabriac
français parlaient d'opinion une
conversation est une des choses qu'il a
dites c'était 1898 les gens sont autour
d'une table on une conversation mais
croient qu'ils sont deux ou trois avoir
une conversation en fait le rôle du
journalisme
le rôle des médias larry va plonger ou
leurs conversations sont plus leur
conversation
ce sont en fait leurs idées suivre le
sillon idées qu'ils empruntaient quand
même à cette époque là bernard cherche
est qu'elles étaient les rails pour
ainsi dire où les raisons nous allons
desquels la perception suivait dans la
société
l'utilisation du big data qui est devenu
un mot clé du présent une phrase clé du
présent c'est tout simplement le chose
qui raffine est ce que permet de
chercher on tarde plus primitifs quand
il a commencé son travail au cours de la
première guerre mondiale
donc vous croyez que les fondamentaux de
sa réflexion sa théorie sont toujours
présents que tout ce que nous avons
changé c'est les l'échelle les outils
les capacités d'atteindre l'esprit des
gens et leur comportement mais
fondamentalement rien n'a changé mais si
vous regardez quelles sont les
motivations
quelles sont les stratégies n'ont pas
changé sauf que les outils ont changé
mais ce qui est intéressant
jimmy parlé précédemment la façon dont
le livre de bernès propagande à a été
publié en france il n'ya que dix ans je
me à ses maîtres republier aux états
unis pour la dernière des esgaulx bernès
était un nom cya
quelque chose l'anecdote que j'ai
apprise quand j'étais étudiant beethoven
et et gaëlle philosophe était sur la
route et napoléon est passé à cheval est
égal se tourner vers beethoven et lui
dit on est témoin du de l'esprit du
monde qui passe à cheval et beethoven
n'a jamais reparlé à égal bernise
représente l'esprit du monde
marionnettiste caché gérer non pas le
sentiment public mais on en parlait à
table tout à l'heure mais la fabrique du
consentement
c'est une façon trop gentil de le dire
parce que sinon on penser la manufacture
la fabrique de l'obéissance
c'est une partie continue notre monde
est très certainement aux etats unis
aussi
il n'y a aucune autre façon de
comprendre le tropisme sans comprendre
cela comme le produit de la fabrique de
l'obéissance en arriver à 30 points
évidence une partie importante de notre
discussion
mais pour continuer compagnie de
technologie ont débuté on les a
considérés comme des outils de
libération liberté changeant ce
paradigme que vous écris
particulièrement quand on est second
google comment cela se fait-il comme les
pauvres fut au début
question compliquée parce que l'internet
a été développé par l'armée américaine
pas simplement par un groupe de gens qui
cherchaient la liberté bien livre qui a
été publié récemment aux états unis dont
le titre échappe
ma visite est qui s'occupe de retraite
de étrange relation entre le militaire
et l'utilisation d'internet est ce que
beaucoup de gens en vue
c'était que l'internet créé l'espace
public
l'agora roche où tout le monde pouvait
prendre part à une discussion
fondamental à l'idée de la démocratie
qu'est la developer xviiie siècle
ici aux etats-unis et ailleurs mais la
france les états unis principalement la
différence bien sûr c'est que l'internet
est un espace public où les individus
sont isolés et les relations entre cet
espace public et les possibilités de
conscience publique en tant que public
et de discussions publiques et
d'activités d'activisme public c'est
très compliqué lorsque des gens qui sont
devant leur petit écran
regardant l'histoire de façon
extrêmement isolées
et dans le même temps ça offrait la
possibilité une sorte d'interaction qui
était auparavant inimaginables
ça crée aussi un public beaucoup plus
insulaire individualisé isolé qui crée
un terrible problème pour notre avenir
qui se règle d'or à bernex ge
aujourd'hui ce serait un ingénieur
informatique qui conçoit des algorithmes
une des raisons pour lesquelles elle
doit bernès est intéressant et a été
traduit il ya 10 ans français les
traduit des ro publié disons en anglais
il ya une dizaine d'années aux états
unis avec le fait que son livre
précédent
il s'appelait cristalliser l'opinion
publique publiée en 23 1923 puis des
raisons pour lesquelles bernès der
publiés c'est parce que il parle la
génération d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire je
connais beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
impliqués dans des formes contemporaines
de la persuasion et de l'affluence qui
retournent vers pernez comme si on a
parlé du pape ici tout à l'heure comme
le primat le saint prime un de la
persuasion
une des raisons pour laquelle le fils
jamie a une résonance aujourd'hui c'est
que beaucoup de manières bernese et
comme je le dis précédemment et l'esprit
du monde de notre temps il n'était pas
seul il ya beaucoup de gens comme
connaissent il attend pour laquelle on
connaît bernès aujourd'hui c'est parce
que il a écrit à son sujet il a écrit il
a parlé de lui moi comme beaucoup de
gens des rp qui veulent rester vraiment
mais c'est trop tôt propre auto promu
par les livres écrits dans les années 20
il écrit son autobiographie qui
s'appelait l'autobiographie d'une idée
c'est à dire l'idée de la propagande et
se l'approprier mais bernese faisait
partie d'une génération de gens qui
avaient travaillé pour la dans la
machine de propagande militaire le
comité pour l'information publique au
cours de la première guerre mondiale
est ce qu'il s'est passé à l'époque
c'est que ces gens milieu qui étaient
des gens des médias des experts de la
spéciale et de la persuasion des
publicitaires
les réalisateurs de films les orateurs
le coup ont été recrutés la commission
d'information de l'îlot qui s'appelle la
cruelle comme un chien du nom du son
dirigeant crible plus riche et la
commission creel été démantelé sept
jours après l'armistice il y avait tout
un groupe de gens qui venaient
journaliste de la radio joue qui avait
compris l'intérêt de leur travail à une
échelle nationale
donc il y avait sept l'émergence dans
les années 20 le scanner a pris appelé
la profession de la com - c'était pas un
individu isolé
raison pour laquelle est devenu imminent
c'est que en fait ils savaient ce qu'ils
faisaient et bernès balle aux gens
d'aujourd'hui et les jeunes dont je
parlais sont dans le marketing dans la
réalité virtuelle dans la gestion de
données ce sont des gens qui regardent
et qui apprennent de bernay c'est pour
ça que sert publiés vous avez mentionné
et sa victoire a ouvert les voies
beaucoup de questions beaucoup d'un
débat ils sont au coeur de discussions
d'aujourd'hui sur les fesses news sur la
manipulation sur la poste vérité ces
concepts vie sud
il existait mais bon qui sont après la
victoire de donner l'effet d'un natif
une autre de ses concepts que se
passe-t-il qu'est ce que tu aimes pas
déclenchée on parle de douar brno
manipulation de façonner l'opinion
publique
qu'est ce que notre homme nous dit à ce
sujet j'ai bien une des choses centrale
principale au sujet de train c'est que
il a mis le monde sens dessus dessous
c'est à dire la vérité toujours été
l'idée le journalisme n'est pas
simplement une réunion scientifique de
données qui sont ensuite présentés au
grand public de façon totalement
objective le journalisme a toujours eu
des motifs et des visions sous jacent il
ya cent ans william james le philosophe
américain écrit un livre qui écrit
primatice pragmatisme gelé les cités
dans pire il ya 22 ans a regardé je suis
là aujourd'hui
une des choses qui m'a écrit dans son
livre sur le pragmatisme pragmatisme
j'avais concept de vérité du pragmatisme
de ces chapitres la vérité le résultat
qui est inhérent à ce même là la vérité
arrive ça devient la vérité par un
processus de présentation et de
vérification c'est vraiment une vision
très intéressant pour ceux d'un côté
c'était d'une d extrêmement démocratique
l'idée qu'il faut pas accepter des
vérités qui nous sont délivrés par des
rois et des sceaux vrai l'idée que si la
vérité
arrivé à une idée si vous le dites
suffisamment s'éprouver suffisamment ça
devient la vérité et pendant longtemps
aux états unis où les institutions comme
le new york times la télévision chaîne
cbs le washington post
c'était des institutions qui avaient
l'imprimatur de la vérité je regardais
sur l'édition internationale du pain
différents de ce on à la maison c'est
beaucoup plus critique que celle que
nous avons obéi
ce qui manque c'est que en eau du titre
7 à gauche à droite c'est la météo et à
gauche il ya toutes les informations qui
méritent d'être imprimé ce que ça
signifie c'est que pendant très
longtemps
v7
ces autorités qui semblaient être les
présentateurs non pas de la vérité
divine mais des recherches qui devenait
vérité on y avait une certaine arrogance
on n'avait jamais de journaux comme
libération aux états unis on n'a jamais
eu un journalisme qui était vraiment
diversifié on n'a pas de parti très
diversifiée on a les deux côtés de la
même pièce en ce qui concerne notre
système politique
ce que votre homme à faire c'était de
je dis qu'il a mis le monde sens dessus
dessous
en fait il a il a transformé les canaux
de de vérité en quelque chose qui
vendait des mensonges
il a vendu la guerre en irak
grâce à des journaux qui ont vendu et
des paquets qui était préparé pour
l'égalité par les militaires oui plus
tard les journaux ont commencé à se
critiquer eux mêmes exactement ses
journaux se critiquer ont commencé à se
critiquer pour avoir vendu l'idée de
destruction massive
c'était comme un théâtre de marionnettes
ce que trump a compris ce que si on a un
système où il y aura toujours des
marionnettistes impliqué dans la
présentation des informations et
certains secteurs du public américain
ce sempé éliminé amputé de la vision de
la vérité qui était présenté par ces
médias
c'est très facile
beaucoup de gens de voir les médias du
maine stream des médias principaux les
médias commerciaux qui travaillent tous
pour le système du business qui s'était
effondré internationalement en 2008 les
considérer comme une machine de
propagande et donc lui a pris le terme
propagande vous les faites news
c'est une autre façon de dire la chose
c'est la montrer sous les projecteurs
sur les grands médias
est ce que ça signifie que danseur
narratif trump serait comme un mouvement
de résistance à edward bernays et la
fabrication du consentement
je ne pense pas ce qu'il a fait c'est
qui comprend bernese mieux que le new
york times a pris à leur propre jeu
vous avez parlé au départ au début de la
terminale âge il est habile jeu de la
propagande la démocratie il ya beaucoup
de ces contradictions apparentes qu'ils
sont vivants dans notre monde etats-unis
qui a vécu à paris pendant un certain
temps
tallahassee qods le dossier de
réparation en sus sur les politiques qui
sous tendent le système du racisme
particulièrement ce qui concerne allez
les noirs une des choses dont ils
parlent
la démocratie et la suprématie blanche
était compagnon de voyage et c'est
probablement aussi vrai en france comme
on n'est pas tellement différente
le colonialisme l'impérialisme américain
sont des moments différents dans la
tendance au long cours à bagan été
développée raison
bernès était intéressé par puisque les
gens l'avaient l'idée arrogante que
leurs pensées d'importantes bernise
rendu compte ces vieux système de règles
ne fonctionnait plus l'aristocratie
nayar chiklis et 6 étaient plus
pertinent quand ce qui était nécessaire
c'est une création jeu d'ingénieurs
invisible outil magnifique pour gérer la
démocratie que les gens puissent
continuer à croire que le groupe revoit
et est entendu et dans le même temps que
le pouvoir exécutif pourrait faire ce
qu'il voulait ce que trump a fait c'est
que il a attaché sa politique un certain
sentiment qu'ils sont prévalence aux
états unis nicox cette idée de
suprématie blanche
mais quelque chose qui fermait maublanc
les plus pauvres un sentiment de
supériorité
un sens qu'ils étaient importants
manière telle que les autres n'étaient
pas pourtant les autres les gens de
couleur s'adonner aux blancs à sens
d'importance et une partie de ce qui se
produit dans cette période qui suit le
deuxième guerre mondiale et plus
particulièrement dans les années 60 70
c'est que ces points de vue autrefois
submergé soudain avoir à nouveau une
fois en entendant des gens qui
descendent c'est être analphabète et
trompe centile ressentiment que
qu'avaient ces gens est lui-même
résultat de ce ressentiment
le père de john sellar d'illusions son
argent j'étais dans l'immobilier
il avait interdit aux noirs d'habiter
dans la maison qu'il construisait son
père était marcher main dans la main
avec le ku klux klan la famille jump
ligne et la suprématie blanche et et le
fait d'appeler les mexicains des
violeurs et des criminels
c'est pas différent parce que le kkk
disait des noirs problématique siècle
qu'est ce que tu me fais je pense que
vous l'avez tous vu quand tu vois la
différence de tous les autres politiques
j'ai vu et il a des meetings tout le
temps moi j'ai jamais vu un président
des etats-unis qui avaient des meetings
tous les deux jours et dans ses meetings
il va dans divers endroits qui sont en
faveur de ses idées sur rendre du
pouvoir à ceux qui n'ont pas de pouvoir
défendre la suprématie blanche entre les
autres ensembles les états unis en un
endroit qu'on ne dit plus entre
guillemets bien sûr ses discours chaque
fois qu'il fait un discours
il recrute des gens qui se tiennent
derrière lui quand vous voyez lui dans
un meeting s'est passablement trump sur
un podium mais il ya des centaines de
personnes derrière lui qui ont tous été
formés par quelqu'un mais pour applaudir
follement à chaque chose qu'il va dire
et ils ont aussi été commandés
atul tatoués avec des petites
représentation de la diversité
vous allez voir un visage noir et ce
visage noir sur un corps un t-shirt
blanc qui disent les noirs pour john
eales deux femmes et qui dit femmes en
faveur d'autres joueurs et puis y'a pas
mal de camionneurs et de gens qui
portent des casquettes rouges lui que
l'amérique soit grande a new way à
nouveau mais en fait ça veut dire que
l'amérique soit blanche à nouveau
beaucoup de façons c'est l'utilisation
de ce symbolisme d'être un homme du
peuple et d' avoir le peuple derrière
soi sur scène ça c'est remarquable que
ça soit fait par intuition un génie
intuitif je crois que c'est le cas c'est
pas un intellectuel très irritable le
mans il y joue sur l'anti
intellectualisme qui est la ligne
directrice de la société américaine
donc il fait du berner sans avoir lu
bernès il connaît quelqu'un qui a lu
bernès probablement mais pour la plus
grande partie son style la culture
populaire américaine vous allez savoir
parce qu'un film américain
le très populaire américaine il ya deux
genres qui était dominant premier ces
gars de l'ouest
john wayne le western le western met
l'accent sur l'individu qui ne paient à
personne d'autre qu'à lui-même
et d'une certaine manière lui c'est une
représentation des comportements
libertaire qui est prêt à tuer n'importe
qui qui se mettra en travers de sa route
et ça fait partie du charme horrible de
la tradition western et l'autre
tradition s'il aime les films de
gangsters
il faut vous rendre compte qu'il vient
de l'industrie du bâtiment
toute personne qui a passé suffisamment
de temps à new york
regardez comment l'industrie du bâtiment
fonctionne c'est que l'industrie du
bâtiment
historiquement avec d'autres industries
comme ont été dirigés par la mafia ou
d'autres organisations criminelles et
donc si vous voulez faire des affaires à
new york
il faut savoir acquis payé un dessous de
table et il faut savoir à qui faire
confiance et à kiel pas faire confiance
il ya un lien secret qui se développe
entre cela entre vous et les gens que
vous payez et ce lien secret est basé
sur linux vous allez payer mais si
jamais il vous dénonce vous vous allez
les éliminer les gens autant de choses
ils sont
sous enquête
bien qu utilise le langage des des gangs
pour pour parler de celui là c'est un
bon gars l'autre c'est une balance
on essaie la langue du gangster et de
personnes qui travaillent dans certains
domaines
ah non c'est vrai depuis très longtemps
moi j'ai grandi et que ces gens là donc
beaucoup de mes amis leur père étaient
des gangsters
j'ai grandi dans le queens en longtemps
c'est de là que vient trump s'est
infiltrée par le grave séisme
je le comprend instantanément parce que
je travaille dans une université qui
fait partir de cette ville de new york
du système politique de la ville dur et
j'ai vu des flaques et d'argent pour ça
de l'université où les doyens donner de
l'argent à des professeurs obéissant
pour rien rater mon copain on prend un
pot le travail tient place en mille
dollars passe du bon temps prend du bon
temps
donc ça fait partie la culture ça parle
aux jambes avec les criminels dans les
films de gangsters sont toujours les
héros les tueurs sont toujours
romantique qui met sa casquette de
baseball rouge qui est devenu un symbole
de la culture des camionneurs qui est
aussi une industrie longue histoire de
l'association criminelle et ce qui se
trouve être le cas c'est que ce soit
il est entouré de jean bergé du marais
les espèces les plus frappants de la
scène américaine vu d'ici en tout cas
c'est la polarisation le fait que les
américains ne lis pas les mêmes
informations ne crois pas aux mêmes
informations en la vérité on est soit
foxnews soit new york times la base pour
la société pour la communauté n'existe
plus est ce que c'est quelque chose que
tu utilises tout d'abord c'est quelque
chose qui se produit lorsque on a
remplacé les cheminées des arbres par la
télévision
vous êtes un grand pessimiste je suis
pas un pessimiste je suis un optimiste
parce que je pense que le changement
c'est difficile on a parlé déjà nous
vivons dans un monde certainement aux
états unis les gens veulent la
gratification tout de suite il veut leur
compte ou de suite ils veulent un
changement immédiat un des histoires en
tant qu'historien se lancer c'est que
changement ça prend du temps
je crois que avec cette division de la
société une utilisation du big data pour
systématiser bien vu mais insatisfaction
grandissante des choses qui se
produisent encore trompe dans le
michigan
l'endroit qui a cette foule qui la place
derrière lui ils ont été formés pour ça
en écoulant les portes et reviennent de
voir vient de voir les gens et pose la
question est ce qu'il dit quelque chose
qui peut vous énervez ou vous rendre
mettre en colère dit non non non je
crois tout ce qu'il dit ce sont des gens
qui ne sont même pas dans la démocratie
sur des gens qui sont tombés amoureux de
job ils ont projeté sur lui les choses
qu'ils ont senti mais qu'ils étaient
n'arrivait pas à dire projet de celui
des choses qui leur manque d'eau propre
vie mais simultanément la population des
états unis et dans un de changer cette
organisation voici les gens les gens les
gens se rencontrent
localement des façons qui de mon point
de vue est très prometteuse chose le
fait qu'un socialiste ou qui quelques
socialistes qui soit arrivée des
positions de pouvoir aux états unis ce
quelque chose qui ne s'est pas produite
depuis 100 ans où il y avait fait
référence
ceux qui ont remporté les primaires pour
les élections du milieu du mandat nous
de choses qui m'intéressent antijeu
trempe qu'il est hays dans sa propre
ville on a aussi une grande dose de l
époque où il était plus un playboy
sur la couverture du magazine dean
croise les gens très mauvaise opinion de
lui
il fait partie de la mythologie
américaine du de l'escroc des grandes
villes qui va essayer de d'essorer et
les gens des petites villes mais cette
fois ci les gens aiment ça c'est bizarre
d'autres choses se produisent y avait
une recherche récente sur la population
des états unis en 2018 le pourcentage de
la population qui est né à l'étranger
est plus importante que ça n'a jamais
été depuis 1906 c'est à dire au milieu
de cette grande période de migration de
gens qui venaient du mezzogiorno
l'italie qui venaient d'europe de l'est
ces gens ont été aussi maltraités à
l'époque répète un petit peu ces
anciennes ses forces en immigration de
l'époque jean qui promouvait l'eugénisme
pour tenter de diminuer la fertilité des
êtres inférieurs et aussi des tentatives
réussie d'ailleurs contre les noirs mais
découragé les empêcher de façon violente
parfois de voter nous faire retourner
violemment car cette démagogie qui a
inspiré
benaize ce que gustave le bon disait
c'est pas un technocrate
mais pour poursuivre sur dix reçoivent
est dit dans les dernières pages de
votre livre pia vous êtes un optimiste
c'est vrai sur l'affluence de
l'éducation sur la politisation par les
médias par comparaison avec le début du
20e siècle il y à l'évidence un accès
beaucoup plus important l'information au
savoir
ces choses là se sont démocratisés
surtout verte
et puis au cours des 20 dernières années
on a ce sentiment que on va faire un
retour en arrière
c'est l'histoire ne va pas toujours de
l'avant ça fait partie de ces idées de
des lumières du progrès je dirais deux
choses de ce monde si vous allez
conclure un livre avec eux le pouvoir de
la persuasion vous mais aussi parlé des
marionnettistes qui sont derrière
l'instrument acte isation de persuasion
il faut encourager le lecteur à croire
que une souviennent possibilité d'avoir
quelque chose de mieux vous parce que
c'est une des médias c'est simplement
sur toutes les façons dont les médias
sont en train de nick et votre cerveau
pardonnez moi pour mon langage
en anglais on dirait pardonnez mon
français
mais bon c'est tout ce que vous faites
alors ce que vous faites ce que vous
encourager les gens à voir ce sentiment
d'impuissance et notre autre chose au
sujet de la puissance c'est que ça rend
les gens impuissant
dommage c'est important pour que les
gens puissent imaginer leur puissance
potentielle pas en tant qu'individu mais
en tant que peuple mais la femme et
isation les médias par les médias un
sujet intéressant parce qu'on parle de
cela beaucoup en france le gouvernement
a annoncé que lé doublé les budgets
l'apprentissage des médias à l'école
c'était comme une façon de s'opposer au
fait quid des théories des conspirations
créer de meilleurs citoyens pour
l'avenir et pas de véritable preuve que
ça fonctionne quand vous regardez les
états unis tout d'abord il faut regarder
la question de la connaissance et de
l'alphabétisation ce que ça veut dire
est ce que ça signifie que comme
certaines personnes au début des années
du 20ème siècle dans le business
les gens disaient il faut apprendre aux
gens à lire et à écrire pour qu'ils
puissent mieux obéir aux ordres
la politisation une histoire la plupart
des gens dans l'histoire n'était pas
apte à bêtises et c'est la raison pour
laquelle l'alphabétisation est devenu un
problème une question en sociaux du 19e
siècle dans le xxème siècle parce que
l'accusation n'est pas simplement quand
on nous enseigne on disait sécurité
rendue
testez les mensonges leurs livres oui
c'est quelque chose il faut comprendre
les manières dans la rhétorique d'un
côté si utiliser correctement peut
illuminer les gens les rendre heureux
d'un autre côté ça peut aussi masquer la
réalité
tous les gens pourront finalement
travail contre leurs propres intérêts
mais l'idée de fabrication qui le
mouvement les mouvements pour le fab et
isation mouvement ça a été tellement
fondamentale les mouvements sociaux
populaires et d'élargir l'univers de
discuter d'idées et pas simplement
d'apprendre à lire et apprendre à écrire
l idée que apprendre à lire à écrire
élargirait le périmètre d'idées des
gentils historiquement été rendu muet
l'histoire est bien que cela soit vrai
nous sommes dans une époque assez sombre
en ce qui concerne les développements
l'utilisation de la psychologie des
masses pour mobiliser des gens une façon
qui sont extrêmement dangereuses
l'époque où il ya une explosion décrit
la voie à des idées qui n'ont pas angie
qu'inwi je parlais de lascaux ce sont
les c'est sûr
2 c'est la réparation rend cette
institution du racisme sassine à des
noirs aux lycées répartis informations
quotidiennes et dit attendez c'est pas
simplement quelque chose qui se produit
maintenant c'est quelque chose qui se
produit parce que il ya une histoire de
différentes politiques qui a assuré la
ghettoïsation des noirs que d'une
certaine manière c'est rendre le présent
lise 10 pour fournir aux gens une
mémoire historique et c'était une des
tâches de l'alphabétisation et ça se
produit regardez le film de jimmy hunt
s'est fait partie de l'univers de la
conversation et la discussion a été très
critique des médias aux états unis et ça
s'applique aussi s'appliquer à la france
et à l'europe de la même manière si vous
vivez ici
certaines de ces critiques sont
légitimes et certainement et sont
partagées par beaucoup de faire ça mais
dans le même temps paru et réseaux
sociaux ont été considérés incertain
quand on a commencé notre site web
rue89 la nécessité que les gens
pourraient prendre en main ces réseaux
sociaux produire non pas d information
alternative mais
la meilleure façon de faire
l'information ça s'est pas produit non
ça s'est produit aujourd'hui nous
faisons face à des médias de
décrédibiliser les médias décrédibiliser
et des réseaux sociaux qui n'a pas
qu'ils sont devenus en fait des champs
de bataille pour des idéologies rival ou
des groupes de m
avec ak systèmes d'information qui est
moins crédible
le système d'information à contribuer à
cela lorsque le simple fait que chaque
jour il faut sortir un nouveau journal
qui contient des chaussées sont
nouvelles et trump est fantastique pour
ça une des choses dont gustave lebon a
parlé quand il a parlé des dirigeants à
la fin du 19e siècle
je suis désolé d'aller en arrière dans
les dunes présenté moi je pense que la
mémoire est importante et la perte de
mémoire
cette diminution de mémoire est une des
choses les plus dangereuses
parmi nous dans les bras de riz a écrit
son livre - fahrenheit 451 une des
choses que ça a créé ce monde dystopique
c'est que personne ne pouvait plus se
souvenir de quoi que ce soit et
l'oblitération de la mémoire très
importants comme le bon ou simplement
regarder les dirigeants de la fin du 18e
siècle la commune de paris c'est ce
qu'il a vraiment rendu dingue
il a dit les dirigeants parlent en
images et jacques l'image suit l'autre
image comme une lanterne magique
il n'y a pas de lien entre les images
l'une avec l'autre
mais il n'y a pas de connexion logique
mais elle devait une sorte de pseudo
narration se dorait si c'est ce que fait
twitter twitter et la lanterne magique
d'aujourd'hui le fait qu'on a un
président des etats-unis qui est sur
twitter dix fois par jour est une façon
de créer du monde en général
je veux revenir sur ce que vous avez dit
au devoir vous avez dit je suis critique
des médias non je ne suis pas critique
des minimes les médias sont des outils
d'expression publique
je ne suis pas un critique de la presse
imprimée
c'est peut être utilisé de façon pour
émanciper les gens et c'est peut être
utilisé aussi pour réprimer les gens
la véritable question c'est je pense que
ça c'est le la question aux yeux de
femmes et isation si on est sérieux au
sujet de ce que l'on dit sur la
connaissance des médias
il faut encourager public être capable
de voir pas simplement ce que
l'information des médias ou la
désinformation des médias
mais avoir des structures pour qu'il
puisse arriver ce qui nécessaires pour
remplir leurs aspirations démocratiques
autre chose qui devrait être fait c'est
que il faut différence entre un
auditoire et à public journalisme
citoyen c'est quelque chose qui a un
impact extrêmement positifs aux
etats-unis en tout cas le meurtre de
héricourt policiers sur stade anal
ça fait partie du narratif américain
mais policier tue des noirs
depuis qu'il ya eu des noirs libres et
même lorsqu'il n'était pas libre
les contremaîtres les tuer mais
maintenant il ya des gens qui publie sa
légende devrait imaginé ce comme des
citoyens journalistes
imaginez des façons de se réunir en tant
que communauté en d'autres termes quand
quelqu'un dit j'ai donné une interview
ya deux jours l'intérieur m'a dit qu'est
ce que vous dites est quelqu'un qui me
dit je veux pas être manipulés qu'est ce
que vous lui diriez qu'il vient qui ne
veut pas être manipulés je dirais une
somme aussi longtemps que le suspect se
voient comme quelqu'un tu est
susceptible d'être manipulé ces nuls
simplement quand tu te comprends comme
un être humain comme faisant partie
d'une espèce qui a besoin de se
découvrir à nouveau
on sait simplement quand ça se produit
tu peux créer des médias qui sont
critiques interactif veut interactive en
ligne mais interactifs dans la rue la
rue c'est quelque chose de très
important parce que quand les gens se
réunissent dans la rue le pouvoir
tremble pense que les gens se réunissent
en ligne est à nouveau c'est la question
qui contrôle les structures des médias
et qui contrôle les plateformes
technologiques plateforme technique aux
auteurs sont des alliés ou des ennemis
dans ce duel à décrire
bah c'est intéressant parce que si vous
regardez la vallée silice cellcom par
les sociétés de la silicon valley je ne
parle pas avec équivalent français on
utilise twitter
bon mais si vous regardez ce sont les
chinois qui ont développé des
alternatives mais aussi longtemps que
les gens de la silicon valley se sent
dans cette contradiction intéressante
ils sont socialement très progressif
tendent à l'être en termes d'idées des
droits de genre orientation sexuelle
tout type de choses et ils soutiennent
les causes libérales entre guillemets à
une exception
le type qui de la tête de paypal était
enfin il était un soutien de jo mais les
autres ce sont qui était qui
fonctionnait pour obama ils sont
fortement libertaire et ils sont
libertaire d'une manière qui par exemple
lorsque le gouvernement veut les
réglementer d'une manière ou d'une autre
je prenne la même position que
l'industrie du pétrole
la même position que d'autres monopole
mondiaux ambriz depuis
les premiers jours des affaires donc via
une situation sorte de corporatisme
transnationales dire que leur esprit
économique est en fait c'est du beau
langage libertarien qui fonctionne au
niveau public mais en fait ils
réfléchissent sur le plan économique
pour revenir à notre discussion mais
soutenu le problème c'est que les gens
qui sont les propriétaires
les capitaines d industrie comprennent
les motifs de profits sont mus par cela
beaucoup des gens qui travaillent pour
les ingénieurs dans l'informatique
ce sont des libertariens de libertaire
qui ne s'identifient pas aux motivations
capitalistique
donc il ya quelqu'un comme edouard nabe
qui vient de ce monde qui s'est éloigné
des politiques de la jeunesse à et aussi
de silicon valley mais s'il ghosn va
laisser la nouvelle épine dorsale du
capitalisme américain
mais oui absolument mais c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles lorsque l'on
parle de créer des médias alternatifs
il faut trouver
d'autres canaux il faut construire
d'autres canaux il faut probablement
aller plus sur la low tech
parce que la technologie invariablement
n'est relié à l'argent et au pouvoir
dans les années 60 1972 qui s'est
produit au milieu de toutes ces
activités
c'était la création en france
des ateliers populaires aux états unis
la pression de même au sein de l'armée
les soldats d'infanterie ceux qui
étaient sur le terrain ont commencé à
tirer quand on lance officiellement et
avec des ronéo présenter leurs propres
journaux mais là on va dans l'autre sens
et agnès et du voile noir harry présente
d'avenir avec l'intelligence
artificielle le relier au cerveau humain
[Musique]
d'avenir technologie qui forment notre
monde et qui créera d'autres
d'inégalités et d'autres luxueuse
la question c'est où où est où sont les
alternatives une partie de l'attraction
l'interaction entre le cerveau et la
machine c'est qu'il ya certaines
personnes qui prétendent que puisque nos
cerveaux sur simplement des ordinateurs
ça vient
la théorie computationnelle de l'esprit
de lento ring et considère l'ordinaire
l'ordinateur comme fac similé du
fonctionnement du cerveau il ya aucune
preuve de cela si vous voulez comprendre
aux bâtiments vous savez regarder le
réseau électrique réseaux de plomberie
ça vous dit rien sur ce façon dont les
gens vivent à l'intérieur de cet
appartement
l'attraction des interactions cerveau
ordinateur c'est que les gens qui disent
qu'à l'avenir on sera capable de
télécharger votre cerveau sur une
machine et vous serez immortel pour
votre corps à mourir mais votre esprit
survivre à bhl et se rattacher à une
machine
c'est une sorte de d'un christianisme de
high tech la vie après la vie c'est une
promesse d'une vie après la vie
une des choses qui doit être une
chose que les gens réalisent
immédiatement c'est la mortalité
une fois que l'on soit capable de
comprendre qu'on est mortelle à cela on
trouvera un but ce que vous allez faire
de votre vie
c'est ce que votre vieux patron jean
paul sartre à dire la vie en elle-même
nasson un sens que par l'engagement
je crois que c'est vrai et espérer que
c'est l'avenir mais termine
technologiquement n'y a rien de neuf
c'est quelque chose qui existe depuis
toujours fait longtemps que j'ai entendu
quelqu'un qui cite jean paul sartre
excusez moi je suis un vieux on va
prendre quelques questions du public
j'ai une gestion statistique je trouvais
absolument étonnante en 2000 il y avait
65 mille neuf cents journalistes aux
états unis et 128 mille personnes qui
travaillaient dans les relations
publiques un pour deux en 2015 15 ans
plus tard le nombre de journalistes a
diminué d'un tiers à 45 millions à 45
millions et le nombre de gens des rp
s'est accru à 200 18000 donc il ya un
journalisme pour cinq personnes des rp
qu'est ce que ça dit sur notre monde
journalistes
je trouve ça
effrayant c'est effrayant mais ça vous
dit aussi que l'urgence la location du
consentement est devenu de plus en plus
grande et l'urgence de travailler avec
un public informé je suis devenu quelque
chose que les structures voire sont de
moins en moins intéressés à voir sans
qu'on peut regarder ça titille comme
celle-là façon différente
une façon de voir c'est que les gens ne
sont pas intéressés à comprendre le
monde dans lequel ils vivent
peut-être que les gens sont intéressés à
comprendre le monde qu'il faut mettre
plus d'ingénieurs du consentement pour
que l'on puisse traiter ses désirs
je ne pense pas que les gens aient perdu
de leur curiosité n'ont pas perdu leur
colère sur les inégalités de pouvoir
c'est l'homme de paille qu'il veut
mettre devant cirque invisible dans les
médias à travers le monde
quotidiennement mais derrière derrière
le décor ce qui se produit positivement
le bug horrible et c'est quelque chose
qui fait partie d'un plan conservateur
ailleurs depuis longtemps mais non j'ai
mes yeux le l'aboyeur qui pourrait se
tenir devant les foules et les distraire
distraire véritable problème de leur vie
parce que
l'inégalité konan qui croit la pression
la souveraineté populaire croix et
dieuze les salaires du banc des cols
bleus sont de stagner alors que les
revenus des très riches pas simplement
là pour ça mais probablement les les 10%
en une chose s'assure que iain une
classe moyenne supérieure qui seront des
porte parole des conservateurs
et dans ce cas là il ya des gens
ailleurs qui se bat avec le chômage nous
avec des tas de problèmes qui sont menés
par le bout du nez par cet aboyeur et
moi j'ai rencontré des gens qui m'ont
dit j'aurais voté pour bernie sanders
aux lieux j'ai voté votre choix
parce que sanders n'avait aucune chance
et ça c'est la façon de voir à quel
point les gens sont manipulables qui ne
peuvent plus faire la différence entre
la halle au dessous mais aussi 7 6 2
comment dirais-je cet entrepôt de colère
des gens qui ont été privés de leurs
droits et ça mène différentes directions
et s'amener à l'élection de ce président
impossible si vous regardez ses meetings
depuis 2015 n'était pas difficile de
voir qu'il deviendrait président a
raison parce qu'il mettait dans les gens
dire aux gens que
dire aux gens de me battre de casser la
gueule à tous ceux qui n'étaient pas
d'accord avec quatre autres autrefois on
aurait pu dire vous êtes contre moi vous
sortirez sur un brancard
et vous savez quoi si vous n'êtes pas
avec moi un coup de pied 12 dé lui un un
coup de poing dans le nez et je vous
fournirai mon avocat maintenant mon
avocat lui aussi de voir les tribunaux
si vous avez des questions vous avez dit
dans un film que les gens commençaient
cette propagande n'aurait pas la fin que
ça durerait pendant des générations
je suis pas français je veux poser une
question dans le film vous avez dit que
le que les gens qui ont qui ont qui ont
quant à eux qui ont fait la pole qui ont
payé pour pour certaines choses de
propagande on allait d'indépendants les
générations je ne sais pas si
si vous n'avez pas faire quelqu'un
particuliers ou pas c'est une question
importante en partie parce que des
tendances plus progressistes dans notre
société ne pense pas de génération en
génération
nous avons ce désir pour récompense
immédiate
si vous voulez parler d'eux en 36
lorsque roosevelt dans campagne pour la
présidence il fait la guerre contre la
classe les entreprises
il les appelle les royalistes économique
il disait on va leur prendre leur
pouvoir on le voit un type dans le film
et à la fin des années 30 il y à
différentes organisations qui se
regroupent
l'une d'entre elle mentionné dans le
film c'est l'association nationale des
entrepreneurs facture qui est très
importante des chambres de commerce qui
est une pouvoirs importants aux états
unis il ya aussi un groupe de gens ils
sont intéressés par la création d'une
identification entre la chrétienté des
dieux et le capitalisme une raison pour
laquelle sur les billets de banque
américains il est décrit nous croyons en
dieu
nous avons confiance en dur et une
gourde ou 3,50
on a eu sur les billets dont le
développement d'organisations comme les
départements d'économie à l'université
de chicago
jean guy ont vu la vitalité du
capitalisme et la longévité du
capitalisme comme étant mise en danger
et qui ont établi des plans
jeux jeux à long terme même si on n'aime
pas on ne voit pas la fin ils ont agréé
il faut les créer quand même y avoir
confiance que ça va arriver à son but
cependant ils ont mis directement
il y avait des recrutés les
l'association nationale des fabricants
était un jeune acteur du nom de ronald
reagan
durant les années 40 est devenu un porte
parole contre le système de santé
national
et puis a travaillé pour general
electric
il avait un tuteur quelqu'un qui le
forme est et il passait des usines en
usine
en parlant contre le syndicalisme
general electric est devenue une des
premières grandes sociétés grandes
entreprises à développer des stratégies
pour éviter les syndicats regan est
passé à la télévision dans les années 50
avant tu mériterais qu il était il y
avait une émission
en présentant les produits stade general
electric 60 et 70 en fait d'après il a
été élu au gouverneur de californie et
en 82 du président des états unis et il
utilise la manufacture du consentement
la fabrication du consentement
c'était prémonition de trump il n'avait
pas le côté dur de john bell avait la
même politique tonne exemples d'idées
qui perd colle au début des années 30
pour le rugby qui arrivent au pouvoir
au niveau présidentiel dans les années
1980 et qui croise y grandissent depuis
dont faisait par exemple le parti
démocrate qui et s'éloigne de sa
tradition les programmes d aide sociale
qui était l'héritage du new deal à moi
je considère ronald reagan et maintenant
disons sont l'esprit idéalisé son
fantôme idéalisée comme étant une façon
de voir le jeu à long terme
où est la limite entre cette idée qu'il
y a
cette fabrique à long terme très
efficace et la théorie conspirationniste
s'il en est verte et bleue manipuler
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'est pas manipulé
par surtout et que peut-être que
personne est allé sur la lune
peut-être que l'on s'est en effet
produit toutes ces théories qui traite
ou la définition oui oui la ligne de
séparation
moi j'ai un problème avec cette cette
phrase théories conspirationnistes parce
que toute personne qui a étudié
l'histoire c'est qu'il y a qu il y a eu
des conspirations la papauté a été
expulsé de rome est exilé à avignon par
une conspiration l'assassinât d'abraham
lincoln a réussi grâce à une
conspiration pour éliminer le leadership
de l'union par des anciens confédérés la
conspiration et de rentrer dans ce monde
de et en fait on ne peut pas d'une
histoire sans se rendre compte qu'il ya
des gens qui seraient mises dans
certaines pièces certaines sur madison
avenue
comment fait aujourd'hui s'il est ce pas
tout ça est totalement planifiée bien
entendu en fait aucun d'entre nous n'est
ici vous voyez on a ici on a une petite
clé derrière l'oreille droite et on a
été remonté en descendant ici et moi en
fait mon ressort commencent à se
fatiguer après l'assassinât de kennedy
il ya eu toutes sortes de théories ou
d'être dit mais sur qui a stationné la
position officielle du gouvernement a
été en ligne avec l'individualisme
américain
c'était un loup solitaire pas de
conspiration ne regarde pas le type qui
se trouve derrière le rideau
non c'était un loup solitaire
qui de façon très très agréable a été
tuée quelques jours après donc il vient
on ne peut pas divulguer ce qui a pu le
motiver
dans quel état de gens toutes sortes de
genres qui ont spéculé sur le fait que
l'assassinât d'un président n'est pas
quelque chose qui se produit sans
quelques discussions préalables et donc
le terme théorie de la conspiration qui
devenu un effet misme pour les idées
folles je pense que la façon dont on
peut faire la différence
c'est par l'investigation l'anc est une
des choses qui différencie le bon
journalisme les journalisme dingue c'est
que le bon journalisme basé sur la
recherche
regardez sous les regards des sous sous
les pierres
mettez vos mains dans la boîte à ordures
regarder chercher et les gens doivent
finir par le reconnaître mais le fait
que théorie de la conspiration et jeté
la tête des gens comme une façon de
décrire même enveloppe jamais plaint de
cette théorie de la conspiration il a vu
il est arabe sur le toit d'un bâtiment
dans le new jersey
or selon septembre est arrivé mais lui
il était par dans le niveau du dans le
new-jersey pourquoi cette idée des
groupes de gens fonctionnent en accord
les uns avec les autres dans les
conspirations je ne pense pas que
c'était quelque chose de s'indignerait
le fait qu'il peut y avoir des intérêts
liés au cours de l'histoire
je voulais faire un petit retour en
arrière sur la psychologie des aléas des
lots à planeyse bon ce petit peu loin de
10 sujets actuels parce que simplement
cet homme là il était assez intelligent
il avait tout pour lui et il s'est mis
au service de causes qui apparemment ils
ne pouvaient pas partagé parce que faire
la guerre contre l'autriche et
l'allemagne qui étaient ces pays
d'origine où il y avait de la famille
c'était déjà assez délicat faire manger
du bacon et des oeufs
je pense pas qu'ils donnent une petite
vendange est lui-même aux différentes
raisons et la promotion de la cigarette
je pense pas non plus qu'il fumait alors
finalement qu'est-ce qui le qu'est ce
qui pousse un homme à se mettre au
service du pouvoir est ce que c'est une
espèce de d'ivresse du pouvoir par
procuration c'est ça la question que je
me pose alors l'autre question c'est
plus fier plus vaste qui étaient autour
c'est le contrôle des populations
donc le kop en france contre amos val
joly on a un état central fort donc la
population est contrôlé depuis toujours
de vendre depuis trois siècles
ce qui n'est peut-être pas le cas le cas
aussi efficacement aux états unis
c'était pour ça que la démocratie
américaine était plus efficace une
certaine manière que la française et met
actuellement grâce donc aux gaffes a
donc donc c'est parce que ça c'est clair
la silicon valley donc nous avons
maintenant une espèce de contrôle
général la population en temps réel
qui est extraordinaire et dernier point
quand vous avez évoqué l'immortalité de
l'âme
en vérité c'est déjà fait puisque tous
nos faits et gestes nos moindres pensées
le moindre hésitation sont enregistrés
en permanence
donc il n'y a pas besoin de payer pour
ça on le fait tous les jours à tous
vents
vous avez posé beaucoup de bonnes
questions
je pense qu'il a été délivrée par l'idée
de contrôler les gens sa fille anne
bernex ce que vous avez vu dans le
documentaire que je connais mme était à
sa table et lui disait tu es bête tuée
idiote
il le dit à sa fille tout le monde
pensait que la minorité intelligente
avait une responsabilité envers la
démocratie pour s'assurer que les
masques idiote stupide se comporteraient
correctement y avait beaucoup d'argent
impliqué là dedans et c'est ce qui fait
que les gens peuvent la guerre contre
leur pays d'origine
vous savez bernès des pas un des
dirigeants de la commission sur le bien
public c'était une façon de revisiter
l'histoire
walter et bourg étaient des conseillers
du président wilson waseige voulait
utiliser la force pour faire taire
l'opposition élite monde et bonheur j'en
dis non il faut créer un bureau de la
propagande
est ce devenu les architectes du rose
ils ont choisi qui savent l'être georges
fleurs pour diriger la commission jose
crime était un journaliste qui faisait
des exposés sur le meurtre de mineur par
les gens de rockefeller
donc il était connu c'était vraiment à
la décision intelligente nommé dans
cette commission alors que la guerre
était vue comme la guerre des
businessmen bernese n'était pas un
architecte de la guerre contre
l'autriche et l'allemagne
il faisait partie des gens des
intellectuels qui sont entrés dans cette
industrie de la conformité
quand j'ai de ce que vous avez dit sur
l'immortalité je comprends ce que vous
dites c'est que il y à des
enregistrements qui sont faits on était
soit mort soit vivant et puis soudain il
ya eu des enregistrements c'est à un
lieu intermédiaire
je le sais parce que j'ai mentionné
lapierre
quand mon père était sur le point de
mourir était c'est quelqu'un qui était
très visuel et puis il est devenu
aveugle eu ma mère lui acheter un petit
enregistreur et ils parlaient tous les
jours sur ces ses rêves le fait l'été
nauséeux
je voulais pas être morbide sur ses
souvenirs de son père et lui qui allait
aux bains douches
mon fils qui est un monteur mais tout
cela sur un cd et moi je l'avais sur mon
ipod et j'allais visiter à un ami
j'écoutais de la musique et soudain
j'entends la voix de mon père dans
l'oreille c'est incroyable je les voir
cet homme qui était un des collègues je
vous dis la chose la plus étrange s'est
produite j'écoutais de la musique s'est
soudain mon père a commencé à me parler
je pouvais entendre sa respiration
je pouvais entendre sa voix et c'était
tellement différent que de regarder une
photo qui est gelée qui est morte et
donc je comprends qu'il y à une sorte
d'hymne mortalité qui est possible à
travers
il m'a dit mon père est mort quand
j'avais 13 ans et je donnerai toutes mes
photos si je pouvais simplement avoir un
enregistrement de lui en train de parler
et donc bien sûr il ya ce terrain
intermédiaires et ce qui est différent
au sujet de l'immortalité dont vous
parlez qui sont les données enregistrées
s'est transformée et sujet en d'objets
les mortalités c'est l'immortalité d'un
objet la subjectivité a disparu
le mythe promu sur le transfert du
registre c'est que la conscience
subsisterait maintenant ce serait
simplement des données qui pourraient
être exploitées donc je n'appellerais
pas ça de l'immortalité dans ce sens la
mortalité que je certains recherchent
merci pour ce témoignage personnel
[Applaudissements]
il faut cesser ici avant que votre
ressort ne s'arrête
merci beaucoup c'est vrai merci à tous
d'être présent ici ce soir
cette conversation et je voudrais vous
dire que c'est un des grands plaisirs de
ma vie d'être ici avec vous ce soir je
suis un septuagénaire et je sais que les
idées lesquels je lutte dès que je suis
très jeune sont encore importants sont
encore pertinentes d'immortalité
c'est sur l'engagement c'est sur le but
de la vie que votre vieil ami sartre
beau couple écrit je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être avec lui c'est sûr
[Applaudissements]